j'accueille donc pour débuter ce 7,8 du
20 novembre le docteur sandrine esquerré
bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes médecin coordinateur des centres de
planification dans le département des
yvelines est la première question est
simple un centre de planification
c'est quoi c'est différent d'un planning
familial ce n'est pas la même chose
alors ce n'est pas là une bonne chose
puisque le planning familial c'est le
mouvement français pour le planning
familial
c'est un mouvement associatif militant
pour le droit des femmes et la chose à
savoir c'est que et surtout pour les
jeunes et pour les professionnels en
contact avec les jeunes c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de consultation médicale du
planning familial dans les yvelines
donc il faut se rendre dans les centres
de planification qui dépendent eux du
conseil général centres de planification
qui sont pourtant méconnu moins connu en
tout cas que le planning familial bien
moins connu malheureusement mais voilà
je suis là pour les faire connaître et
on va en parler justement on va voir
comment il fonctionne juste avant un
petit détour par les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines nous sommes allés
poser cette question connaissez vous la
différence entre un centre de
planification et un planning familial
voici vos réponses et on va voir s'il
est encore un peu de travail à faire de
votre côté pour vous faire connaître
planification c'est pour te montrer pour
tous tandis que le centre du planning
familial c'est pour les femmes pour
essayer de pas avoir de bébé tentait
gens veulent pas ou enfin des choses
comme ça quoi
alors ça je ne sais pas du tout un
centre de planification
c'est pour prendre la pilule elles me
semblent pas pour tous ce qu'est
prescription de pilule de contraceptifs
et plané pour moi je retrouve la nique
familial fait la même chose sauf qu'il
ya un médecin
je crois au planning familial je sais
pas ou pas du tout la différence
conseiller pour le chose planification
de cette pauvre plus pour les adultes et
le centre familial
un planning familial c'est plus pour les
pour les étudiants et voilà pour les
jeunes et d'autres c'est plus pour les
adultes pour pour le social des adultes
alors voilà il ya encore du travail à
faire mais vous me disais toute façon
vous avez les mêmes missions en fait
ouais là fondamentalement
fondamentalement nous avons les mêmes
missions
la seule chose qui est très important
dans les yvelines c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de médecins au planning familial et donc
la petite jeune ou la moins jeunes qui
va s'y rendre pour avoir une
contraception sera renvoyée par les
conseillères conjugales du planning
familial vers un des 26 centres de
planification familiale du conseil
général alors justement il ya 26 centres
notamment dans les yvelines
et puis notamment un attrape nous nous y
sommes rendus pour voir comment il
fonctionnait et ensuite nous discuterons
sur ce plateau avec le docteur esquerré
reportage de catherine plateau et
d'élodie moine il existe 26 centres de
planification familiale dans les
yvelines géré par le conseil général
comme ici à trappes dans ces lieux une
équipe composée d'un médecin et d'une
conseillère conjugale et familiale
conseil qui veut sur la sexualité offre
un accès à la contraception et au
dépistage des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
on parle souvent de libération des
moeurs et pourtant face à ces
questionnements
rien n'a vraiment changé chez des jeunes
la sexualité ça reste un sujet tabou
ça reste un sujet difficile à aborder
soit parce que les parents 20 entendant
parler ou ne peuvent pas entendre parler
enfin les jeunes et soit parce que
parfois les jeunes ne veulent pas en
parler parce que c'est leur intimité
ils savent beaucoup plus de choses ils
ont ils ont toujours du mal à mettre en
pratique
mais ils savent qu'ils savent des choses
ils savent que la pilule existe tous les
moyens de contraception a déconné s'y
connaissent des pauses ahmeti la mise le
passage à l'acte à la mise en pratique
est plus compliqué les centres de
planification familiale à ne pas
confondre avec le planning familial qui
est une association sont mal connus des
jeunes générations
et pourtant ici les entretiens sont
gratuits et confidentiels
un colloque sur ce thème s'est déroulée
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'adulte et un
rôle important à jouer dans la
transmission des informations c'est le
message de ce professeur il ya moins
d'autorité naturelle et surtout les
beaucoup d'adultes ne se sentent plus
légitime
on d'intervenir c'est peut-être là ils
sous-estiment l'importance qu'ils ont
pour les ados beaucoup d'adolescents
sensibles ont peur de la déception est à
la place il s'enferme dans des
comportements qu'ils pensent maîtriser
mais qui en général ne les empêche de se
nourrir justement des échanges qu'il
pourrait les valoriser leur donner
confiance en 2011 les 26 centres de
planification des yvelines ont reçu 8500
personnes est assurée 14000 consultation
un projet est en cours pour diminuer le
nombre de ses centres mais leur
permettre d'être ouvert du lundi au
vendredi ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
on s'entasse donc ce soir centres de
planification vous avez vu différents
numéros de téléphone s'afficher je vous
précise juste que le centre de
guyancourt est actuellement fermé on
vous renvoie donc un pas vers le centre
de planification c'est celui de trappes
le numéro là s'affiche à l'écran vous
pouvez les contacter au cours de ce
reportage on vous a entendu nous
expliquer que les jeunes avaient
beaucoup plus d'informations que par le
passé le plus difficile c'est la mise en
pratique
oui et ça fait partie de nos missions
voici alors ça fait partie de nos
missions donc délié jadis l'émission
d'une source de qualification ça va être
de répondre à toutes leurs questions
toutes leurs questions toutes leurs
interrogations sur tout les to ta vie
affective et sexuelle et donc en
particulier sur l'éclat contraception
quels que soient les moyens de
contraception on va pouvoir les
renseigner les prescrire ou leur leurs
données on va être très attentif aussi
répondre à leurs questions ou rechercher
tous les problèmes d'infections
sexuellement transmissibles
ensuite on va bien sûr s'occuper d'eux
des jeunes en particulier lorsqu il va y
avoir des doutes sur les grosses une
grossesse par exemple et puis les
accompagner dans leur réflexion par
rapport à cette grossesse et les
orienter en fonction de leurs choix et
enfin on fait beaucoup d'entretien donc
par rapport à la sexualité homo ce sont
les conseillères conjugales surtout que
les font donc savoir un hymne à quitter
je suis très triste c'est souvent le
garçon qui kafil donc il m'a quitté je
suis très triste
ensuite voilà j'ai un copain je peux pas
en parler à mes parents j'ai un copain
et je me sens pas bien parce que mes
parents ne veulent pas que jamais à ce
genre de choses on peut le discuter dans
les centres de planning quotidien
ta ble ment vous voyez comment évolue la
société à travers ces jeunes forcément
est ce que c'est une évolution
inquiétante ou non est ce que
aujourd'hui il ya moins de tabous ça ce
serait plutôt positif mais est-ce qu'il
ya plus d'attitude de comportement à
risque aussi par exemple alors nous ce
que l'on voit déjà c'est bien parce
qu'ils sont arrivés jusqu'à nous sommes
donc c'est fait l'effort de venir à bout
ils ont été pressés mais voilà il ne
démarche positive qu'en sus spontanée ou
même quand ils ont été adressées
notamment par les infirmières scolaires
ou par les éducateurs on a un gros
travail de partenariat mais envoie tout
le monde y les jeunes ils font ils ont
une sexualité beaucoup de tricot c'est
tout c'est sûrement vrai nous c'est vrai
que ça reste aux alentours de 16 ans et
demi 17 ans les premiers rapports c'est
surtout cette population là que l'on a
dans les centres de planification
on a toujours le cas particulier de la
gamine de 12 ans et demi voilà c'est
rarissime
heureusement par les jeunes qui font la
démarche de venir vous voir se rendent
directement danser dans ces centres
comment vous toucher le public qui ne
vient pas vous voir j'organisais des
réunions vous allez chercher dans les
établissements scolaires aussi les
pouvait rentrer dans les établissements
scolaires alors ça c'est une autre
mission l'autre partie de notre mission
donc en tant que ça centre de
planification
c'est qu'on reçoit dans le centre pour
des entretiens individuels des
consultations gratuites et puis on fait
toute l'information collective au niveau
des établissements scolaires ou lorsque
auprès des publics ne sont pas
scolarisés soit on part des associations
soit au niveau de centres de vie sociale
et l'appareil on aborde ce soit lors la
thématique qui sont choisis ça peut être
uniquement la consente la contraception
ça peut être la prévention de la
violence dans le couple
ça peut être voilà la prévention des
grossesses non désirées très variables
le public est très varié aussi la
fréquentation de différence entre des 26
à travers le département du maine elle
est en hausse
actuellement on a une fille l'actif de
plus en plus importante et de bons
retours aussi les jeunes quand ils
viennent ils reviennent comment
personnes à peu près se rendre dans le
centre sur une année alors dans l'année
donc c'était plus de 8500 personnes vu
au moins une fois et puis de 14 mille
consultations actes médicaux
on va faire juste une petite parenthèse
je vais profiter de votre présence sur
le plateau une parenthèse lié forcément
à l'actualité
votre avis sur la contraception
remboursé à 100% l'assemblée qui a voté
cette gratuité des pilules pour les
jeunes
de 15 à 18 ans et qui était jusqu à la
rembourser à 60 da hauteur de 65%
c'est une bonne mesure bien c'est une
bonne mesure dans la mer ça devrait
favoriser l'accès à la contraception
c'est vrai que ça nous touche moi non
puisque nous nous délivrons la pilule
gratuitement pour les mineurs qui
désirent la confidentialité le
remboursement il et je pense là il
faudra vérifier mais je pense qu'il est
sous tendu à la présentation de la carte
vitale et donc au fait que les parents
vont être informés au moins qui a eu
lieu à remboursement il y aura peut-être
pas marqué ce que c'est mais qui a eu un
remboursement
et donc si la jeune ne peux pas en
parler à ses parents je pense que c'est
pas tout à fait adapté et qu'elle pourra
pas se servir de ce remplacement 100%
des discussions il a plutôt évoqué de
trouver des solutions avec la cpm pour
que ça n'apparaissent pas justement pour
contenir maintenant en tout cas là le
fait que ça reste anonyme un aigle et
part en l1 ne le sache pas sur le sur le
remboursement autres pointent
aujourd'hui à l'actualité remboursement
à 100% des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse à partir de 2013 ça a été
adopté là aussi le 26 octobre par
l'assemblée
alors ça par contre c'est très important
parce que cela touche énormément de
personnes pour les mineurs actuellement
il ya eu des possibilités de prise en
charge totale et dans l'anonymat donc là
tu sais ça va mais le souci c'était pour
les majeurs à les plus de 18 ans qui
voulait garder l'anonymat et pour elle
il n'y avait pas de possibilité de prise
en charge 100% donc là c'est une bonne
chose
le ticket modérateur il reste élevé pour
une jeune de 20 ans quand il faut
avancer 80 euros c'est pas c'est pas
rien donc ça va en tout cas donc dans le
bon sens puisqu'on parle de liberté il y
avait eu cet événement tragique en
irlande le fait que les ivg sont
interdites là bas sauf si c'est lié à un
problème de survie tout simplement il ya
eu un décès puisque l'avortement était
refusée à une mère de 31 ans qui est
décédée donc le 28 octobre
ça fait partie de quelques fois des
inquiétudes que vous pouvez avoir aussi
dans vos centres de se dire que l ivg un
jour peut-être qu'on remettra en cause
en france il ya des discussions qui
s'engagent assez fréquemment autour de
ces sujets alors dans les yvelines on
est relativement
oui on va dire pas protégé on a un très
fort lien avec les centres d'orthogénie
du département les médecins de
planification enfin le médecin du centre
d'orthogénie travaille aussi en
planification familiale c'est on a eu
énormément de liens entre nous une très
bonne prise en charge à ce jour donc
nous on n'est pas trop touché par la
crise on va dire des centres ivg et on
développe vraiment les liens et surtout
on se bat pour diminuer le nombre de
grossesses non désirées
c'est plutôt sur cette lutte lan qui on
se concentre plutôt que sur remise en
cause sinon ce qui concerne la france on
en revient véritablement centres de
planification pour conclure cet
entretien 26 entre dans le département l
idée c pas d'en avoir forcément plus
mais qu ils soient ouverts plus
longtemps parce que là ils sont pas
ouvertes tous les jours ils sont pas
ouverts 7 jours sur 7 24h sans même
théâtre alors déjà si on arrive à les
avoir ouverts du lundi au vendredi avec
un médecin tous les jours au moins une
demi journée
voilà en sachant donc toutes les
consultations sont gratuites tous les
entretiens sont gratuits ce sera déjà
une bonne chose
très proche des centres soient des
centres de vie étudiant comme la faculté
de saint quentin soient proches des
gares voilà on essaie vraiment de
choisir délocalisations qu'il soit
approprié au public jeune puisque c'est
lui qu'on connaissait touchés il sont
paniqués sont c'est vraiment une
spécificité pour eux c'est la
possibilité d'avoir sans autorisation
parentale et de manière gratuite une
contraception
donc il pourrait y avoir une évolution
assez rapide sur la répartition les
horaires d'ouverture où ça reste lié à
des contraintes budgétaires aussi je
pense que là c'est plutôt c'est vraiment
un projet qui est porté par le
département et que ça devrait se mettre
en place
je rappelle quelques chiffres du centre
de planification familiale dans le
département ont corrigé si je me trompe
quinze médecins vacataires 15
conseillère conjugale également 2011 les
1500 jeunes vu au moins une fois
quatorze mille consultations
merci d'être venu donc sur le plateau
nous parler de ces centres vous en savez
dorénavant un petit peu plus et vous
comprenez la différence avec le planning
familial c'était suite de cet entretien
merci à vous on va changer de sujet à
présent d'autres invités vont nous
rejoindre sur le plateau et nous allons
ouvrir déjà une page politique